valorent has a run and gun problem
seriously if i get running sprayed by
the frenzy or the stinger
one more time i'm gonna break my
keyboard
now this issue is bigger than valorent
and it strikes at the very core of its
comparison to counter-strike
and riot's next move could define the
future of the esport
and with that said their latest patch
well it didn't even come close to fixing
the problem
[Music]
guys we're on our way to 2 million
subscribers
on this youtube channel if you like the
videos if you like the score's content
make sure to scroll down hit the
subscribe button and turn on
notifications
so you never miss a video alright so i
think it's safe to say
that riot games's tactical shooter and
competitor to counter strike
valorant is having a bit of a coming out
party lately
the game's average viewership on twitch
has jumped from 50k to 70k
in january and content machines
like nadeshot tim the tatman ninja and
shroud
have turned their attention to valorant
over some of their other favorite fps
titles
oh here we go round two if there's one
thing i've learned
you insta-lock jet and you don't say
anything to your team
[ __ ] even ludwig is playing valerie
one enemy remaining wow
now with all that positivity aside there
is
absolutely a run and gun problem in this
game
and i mean that literally like it's way
too [ __ ] easy to run and shoot
successfully at the same time
and for me to properly explain that we
need to go back to where this
all started counter-strike for all
intents and purposes
valerian is a counter-strike clone we've
been over this
and while it might sound that way that's
not actually
a bad thing in my opinion counter-strike
is the
goat esport it has a massive skill
ceiling
and it is just the most exciting esport
to watch at the highest level
so riot games packaging up
counter-strike giving it some cool
agents
removing terrorists giving it a nice
design
and some fire skins is about all you
need to print money as far as i'm
concerned
with that said counter-strike
real counter-strike the king of fps
games
relies on one extremely important
core tenet it's all about
the shooting exact and masterable spray
patterns
buttery smooth reset times that sweet
sweet source engine movement and of
course
next to no accuracy while moving and
shooting at the same time
and it's here where valorent runs into a
big problem right now over the course of
the last month while the valore
champions tour has gotten underway and
the game has grown a lot on twitch
streamers and pro players have
discovered something
you can kill people pretty easily while
running
so if someone was like this close for
instance
i'm not kidding running spray is
actually good
the frenzy in the pistol round the
stinger on light buys and both the
vandal and the phantom
in gun rounds have been putting up call
of duty like
running spray highlights
i mean tens literally won a death match
only running and shooting with the
phantom
now if you're not an edgy esports fps
head you might be asking yourself
what's the big deal so what if you can
run and shoot
you can do that in most fps games well
when it comes to the competitive side of
games like counter-strike and by
extension valorent
the necessity of standing to aim and
skillfully counter-strafing to combine
your shooting
with movement is core to these games
identities
it's what makes them different it's what
makes them so difficult to be good at
and let me tell you it takes one glance
at my twitter timeline
to say that pros are not happy about
this running and shooting stuff
now well at first many of the complaints
surrounded the game's most popular rifle
the phantom as players continued to
experiment
it became clear that this was a problem
with most of the game's automatic
weapons
in particular the stinger and the frenzy
the game's cheapest smg
and a cheap automatic pistol similar to
the cz in counter-strike
running accuracy is even more broken on
these guns
because the ability to move while
shooting helps you to avoid the higher
power rifles
during your save rounds guys it's really
not that hard to win a gunfight with a
stinger versus a vandal right now
and that really feels bad man now in
reaction to all the run and gun hate
that was being spouted from the
community
riot games stepped in and has done
something to their credit
that they've been doing ever since
valorent got released
they tried to fix it on february 2nd
they dropped patch 2.02
where they said quote this is the patch
where we start to tackle the feeling
that running accuracy
isn't where it should be as we've
mentioned we're taking this on in
increments and are ready to jump in if
you're not comfortable with the changes
we've significantly increased the amount
of error that all rifles get when moving
and shooting to help combat
the sensation of running kills with
rifles these changes will make kills
while moving with rifles more rare
especially at longer ranges but still
possible up close
we'll be monitoring this closely and
will continue to fine-tune
as necessary end quote now as a huge fan
of valor and myself
it's awesome to see riot be willing to
step in and make changes when necessary
with that said
the rifles are only part of the problem
and in the early going it doesn't even
seem like the changes that were made to
them
are enough so what we're left with is
ranked games still being dominated by
stingers
frenzy being the only competitive option
in pistol rounds
and rifles that just still don't work
right what's maybe the most poetic part
of this entire story
is that all of this already happened
in cs go up until 2017 and into 2018
the cz was just too [ __ ]
good in counter-strike you could one tap
people
through head armor with a pistol
very similar to how you can get a 3k in
one spray
with the frenzy in valerian right now
seriously this [ __ ] was a broken
in half
the czech was then nerfed not once but
twice
in 2018 and the cs community has also
already started to draw comparisons
between the stinger now and valorent
and the ump and counter-strike and it's
here where we get to the big picture of
the problem with valerian right now
not only does the game need to do a
better job of learning from its
predecessor's mistakes
in my opinion it also has to do a better
job
of learning from counter-strike's
successes before you scroll down and
freak out at me in the comments for
hating on valerian
i actually love the game it's my
favorite esports title to play right now
and i enjoy it much more than cs go
sorry dimitri but if we as a community
and riot want these easy cs go
comparisons
to finally go away we have to stop
and start to take some of these
criticisms seriously
the frenzy and the stinger they need to
be nerfed immediately
because running and gunning have no
place in a game like this
the fact is it just makes the game
easier it takes that gigantic
skill gap that we're used to seeing with
guys like zyu and simple in cs go
and shrinks it way too much environment
and then you get what we got last week
both first strike finalists 100 thieves
and tsm
being ousted in the first round of open
qualifying for the valerian champions
tour
by basically no-name teams and with that
in mind
i think it opens up an even bigger can
of worms where we
have to ask ourselves should spray
patterns
actually be random in this game right
now at the highest level the biggest
difference between valorent and
counter-strike
are movement and spray patterns in cs
when you hold down your left mouse
button and spray that ak the bullets go
in the same pattern every time
and then you get sickos who memorized
that and become
batshit insanely good at the game valve
actually once tried to make spraying
rifles in counter-strike
less accurate so players would burst and
tap more and
even they yes absentee valve
admitted that they were wrong and fixed
their mistake the rifles and valorent
just aren't like that and at first that
didn't seem like an
insurmountable obstacle but it really is
a contributing factor to all of the
frustrations going on with this game
right now
part of the reason that it's so [ __ ]
easy to
run at somebody's chest and barrel stuff
them with a stinger
is because the vandal and phantom just
aren't consistent enough to level up
they just don't feel good so for me
let's nerf the frenzy
let's nerf the stinger let's tune the
rifles even more
and most of all let's be open-minded
about the criticisms that these
grumpy grouchy old cs go heads have
about our game because it's a dope game
just like cs go
and i love it but it could be better
like most people i got into anime and
university i watched literally just
death note
and then i kind of fell off of it until
i watched hunter hunter i still wouldn't
call myself like an anime guy but
devin hunter hunter is an anime about
friendship it's it's about me and you
i'm going your kilowatt you know we're
looking out for each other's backs
you know